GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So this is using Fourier series.
So I had to pick
an equation where
we were given a
function, and not just
a couple of initial values.
So I made the equation a
partial differential equation.
The most famous one,
Laplace's equation.
So this is the setup.
And you'll see how
Fourier series comes in.
We're in a circle.
I'm going to make this
a nice model problem.
So inside this circle we're
solving Laplace's equation.
Laplace's equation was
the second derivative
of u in the x direction,
plus the second derivative
of u in the y direction, is 0.
That's the way heat,
temperature, distributes itself
when you leave it alone.
In this problem I'm going to put
a source of heat at that point.
So it'll be a point source.
A delta function.
And on the rest of the
boundary, temperature 0.
So the boundary function
is a delta function
with a spike at that one
point, and 0 elsewhere.
And our problem is to solve
the Laplace's equation
inside the circle.
And we use polar coordinates
because we've got a circle.
So there is the
equation with x and y,
but we really are
thinking r and theta.
And the reason is, you
get beautiful solutions
to this equation
using r and theta.
And that was a
family of solutions.
r to the n-th cos
n theta just works.
And so does r to the
n-th sine n theta.
And that's for every n.
So we have-- we can combine.
We have a linear equation.
We can take combinations of
solutions with coefficients
a n in the cosines,
and bn in the sines.
And now here's the key step.
Put in r equal 1.
Put r equal 1.
And then this solution, u
at 1 and theta-- r equal 1--
is the boundary.
It's the circle.
And that's where we're given u
of 1 to be the delta function.
The point source.
The delta function.
Delta of theta.
The point source
at theta equals 0.
So you see our job.
That function, that
boundary condition,
is supposed to tell us
the a's and the b's.
And then we have our solution.
So by putting r equal
to 1 in this formula,
we're supposed to get
the delta function.
So let me put r equal 1.
Easy to do.
It's the sum of a n, 1
to the n-th, cos n theta,
plus the sum of bn, 1 to
the n-th, sine n theta,
is supposed to match
the delta function.
So that's the Fourier series
for the delta function.
That's the whole point.
That we use a Fourier
series expression
for the boundary function,
whatever that boundary function
is.
Here it's a particularly
nice neat one.
And actually, the delta
function is an even function.
It's 0 at theta and
it's 0 at minus theta.
So changing theta to minus theta
still leaves me the spike at 0.
So because it's
an even function,
I won't see any signs.
I won't see any odd functions.
The sine theta.
And I have an easy time
to find the coefficients
a n of the cosines.
Actually, we did that directly
from the formula for the a n's.
Let me just remember
that formula.
The formula was a0 was 1
over 2 pi times the average.
a0 is the average value
of the temperature.
And the temperature on the
boundary is delta theta.
And that integrates to 1, and
we get the answer 1 over 2 pi.
That's the average temperature.
Isn't that a little weird?
The temperature 0
except at one point.
At that point it's a delta
function with the coefficient 1
outside it.
And then we get 1 over
2 pi as the average.
The other a n's, the
coefficients of the cosines,
are 1 over pi, times the
integral of our delta function,
times cos n theta d theta.
And the delta function,
that point source,
picks out that number
at theta equals 0.
And that number is 1.
So I'm getting 1 over pi.
So finally I now
know the a's and b's.
When I put those in, that
tells me the solution.
The solution-- now I can
put r back in the picture--
it's a sum.
Well, let me take the a0 term.
The a0 is 1 over 2 pi--
that's the constant, that's
the average-- plus the sum of
1 over pi cos n theta, from n
equals 1 to infinity.
And r to the n-th.
Sorry. r to the n-th.
So you see what happens.
When r is 1, we have the Fourier
series for the delta function.
That's the very
exceptional function
that's given on the boundary.
As soon as r is less than
1, these r to the n-th's
get small, and we
have a series that
adds up to a reasonable sum.
And we can actually-- it's
possible to add up that series.
It's possible to
add up that series.
It's a geometric series
if you switch from cosines
to exponentials.
That's usually the good
way to get good formulas.
And here, so you can add it up.
And I think there's a 1
over 2 pi still there.
And I think it's 1 minus r
squared, over 1 plus r squared,
minus 2r cos theta.
Let me just be sure
I got that right.
Yep, looks good.
Looks good.
And we could check if it's good.
Let's take theta equal 0.
So if we take theta equal 0.
Let me draw that circle again.
Theta equal 0.
We're coming out on that ray.
And we're expecting to see
infinity when we get there,
at r equal 1.
So theta equal 0.
So let me just put that.
On the ray, theta equal 0.
This is what you should do.
We have a formula
for all r and theta,
but let's look at
some particular points
to see what's happening.
So along that ray,
where theta is 0,
I have 1 over 2 pi, 1
minus r squared, over 1
plus r squared, minus 2r.
Because cos theta is 1.
And 1 plus r squared, minus
2r, is 1 minus r squared.
Right?
Because cos theta
is 1 on this ray.
Theta is 0.
Cos theta is 1.
And now 1 minus r will
factor out of this.
And I think we get 1 plus r.
And we still have a
1 minus r down below.
I like that.
You don't often, for partial
differential equations,
get some nice expression
for the solution.
So that's the solution.
And as r goes to 1,
this solution blows up.
Right.
The temperature is
infinite on the boundary,
but the temperature is
something reasonable inside.
And at r equals 0,
I have 1 over 2 pi.
Well, of course.
It's the average value.
Right at the center
that temperature
is going to be the
average on the boundary.
That's a natural key property
of Laplace's equation.
It averages everything.
Actually, if I take a
little circle in anywhere,
those temperature in the
center of that circle
would be the average
of the temperatures
around the little circle.
For all the circles.
It's just the
Laplace's equation.
Solving Laplace's equation
averages everything.
And the result is that the
temperature function sort of
smoothes out as I come in.
Around the boundary
it's far from smooth.
There's a big jolt
at theta equals 0.
But if I look on that circle,
or that circle, or this circle,
the temperature is a
nice smooth function.
And it's never going to be above
the maximum on the boundary.
And it's never going to be below
the minimum on the boundary.
Everything's being averaged.
So that's, you see, a use
of the Fourier series.
For one particular function.
I could do another function,
but I don't think I will.
I could take the function that's
1 on the top of the circle
and minus 1 on the bottom
half of the circle.
OK, that's a function with a
jump, but not a delta function.
So we would see a Fourier
series that would give us
the a's and the b's.
There would probably
only be b's in that case.
Sine.
Sine terms.
And we'd get an answer.
May I just, while I'm
talking about averages,
add one final comment.
Usually, for a
complicated region,
we can't solve Laplace's
equation with formulas.
It's not possible.
We can't find sines and cosines
that match some crazy boundary.
So we have to replace
Laplace's equation.
So I'll write Laplace's
equation again.
That goes into u--
we have a region.
And we carve it out with a grid.
And then at each
point on the grid,
we have an equation connecting
the value of u at that point.
Say u0 at the center.
With u east, maybe, u
west, u north, and u south.
So we have an
equation, and I want
to write that equation down.
u center is just going
to be the average.
It's just going to be 1/4 of
u east, u west, u north, and u
south.
So that'll be true at--
that equation will hold.
The unknowns are all these u's.
The u's of all the mesh points.
And I have an equation
at every mesh point.
So I have the same number of
equations from the mesh points
as unknowns at the mesh points.
I solve that big system, and
that gives me a solution u.
An approximate solution
u to Laplace's equation.
So this would be called
Laplace's difference equation,
or Laplace's five-point
scheme, because it uses
five points in that average.
OK.
That's an important problem
in numerical analysis.
Thank you.